hi my name is Gustav if you don't know
now you know your life is different now
I'm sad inside but use tangible
aesthetic pieces of clothing to make
others think I'm not here's my Black
Friday haul I'm sad I'm sad I'm sad I'm
sad I'm sad inside Oh first door once
you were pulled over 21 the store that
consistently allows me to oh yes this is
a very modest yellow sweater it's very
70s which is not an era I have any
knowledge about but it's really fun as
like a modern fashionista to hijack that
era as a now present-day adjective for
the way you describe your style I'm sad
inside also this yellow color is I think
really fun and fresh and also is
definitely not a way for me to get over
the fact that one time a friend of mine
took some photos of my improv team and I
was wearing a yellow t-shirt during that
and that he emailed them to me said his
PS that yellow was not my color that's a
true story
these jeans that say wear jeans but
we're also gonna have stuff in a weird
way by the end of the night jeans but
also maybe I'm a lizard and nothing I do
has consequences these jeans say I'm
ready to be a stepmom these jeans say
I'm not sad you were sad I'm sad inside
these jeans say skinned knees would be
more attractive these jeans are really
nice for when you want to look nice and
casual and also none of the above so
these are fun necks this I'm sad inside
I thought
came with more this is what everyone
says when they meet this is a super cute
shear Botcon body-conscious dress that
has some like rose embroidery and it's
long sleeve and it's completely
see-through unless you put another
element under it this is the kind of
dress you get when find out that your
high school boyfriend that you broke up
with that you were like good luck with
your life is actually really happily
married and you're currently no this is
kind of dressing you where when you tell
a guy that my eyes are up here and down
here and on my shoulders and just look
at me it's cute I'm doing well I'm sad
and that you know it's cute when it
doesn't fit in the frame at all next is
this no I it's got long sleeves and it's
a deep v putt and it looks like a long
dress but spoiler alert it's not it's
tiny shorts underneath this is kind of
dress you buy when this is the kind of
dress you buy when your ex was really
into superheroes and then you find a
dress that gives you a cape like a
superhero but around your butt you say
I'm the flash I'm sad inside
regardless it's the perfect dress to
wear into like a December wedding or an
office holiday party or the a a meeting
that you promised for close friends that
you go to after the corn and you at
Applebee's at 3 p.m. last Tuesday let's
go to hmm
this is it a dress is it a sweater why
are the arms like that ever youtube
comment I get every day this is a mohair
sweater that I got from H&M which means
that it costs more and
it feels worse like me this is the kind
of sweater that's really bad it's useful
for hiding lots of things secrets a good
secrets baggage it's also itchy that
hits too close to home that's mom bees
I'm sad our these complicated and
difficult and who would wear these and
why like if you're a ninja but you are
also a furry these are just pants if you
just don't know what you're doing
anymore
these pants are like me they're confused
so they're trying-- so people don't get
them them twice and if they're grasping
at straws and no one gets it even they
don't get it anymore and inside thank
you guys so much for thank you guys so
much for watching this Black Friday haul
I hope you enjoyed it if it gave you
inspiration let me know if we to leave a
comment down below on your favorite
Black Friday all peace and if you guys
got any great deals that I don't know
about oh they didn't take the sensor off
this armpit like and comment and
subscribe
I don't know these are the kind of jeans
that say I love boyfriend jeans but I've
never had a boyfriend girls will get
that job this is the kind of jeans to
say I'm not allowed in the mall anymore
I have more clothes to go I will
probably also wear these if you know
anything my mole hair as soon as you put
it in the washer what you're not
supposed to but I do anyway it just goes
mohair mohair